l'anniversaire des 20 ans de la
télé-réalité est ce que pour toi à
l'excès reste que c'est un bel
anniversaire ce qui est c'est vrai que
c'est beaucoup décrié la télé réalité
mais c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui moi quand
je vois toutes ces images
et moi je dis ça fait franchement ce qui
est très surprenant c'est le scandale
que ça générait soient diffusés et
rétrospectivement maintenant c'était un
petit programme pour ados tout gentille
et quoi au final c'était absolument pas
scandaleux c'est ça qui est très
surprenant c'était le mode de captation
évidemment qui surprenait le fait de
voir des jeunes pour la première fois la
télévision c'était très surprenant mais
globalement il ya peut-être une scène
dans une piscine qui a été tué dans une
piscine
je pense à cette scène plongée dans la
musique sans penser à ça vous jure et
c'est vrai qu en vraie love story on va
pas se mentir il ya eu un avant et un
après love story pour la chaîne m6
incroyable
justement moi j'aime bien savoir les
coulisses pourquoi pourquoi c'était pas
ça pas été sur tf1 a love story
alors ça pas été sur tf1 il ya une
longue histoire c'est que il s'était mis
d'accord les deux patrons et le patron
de tf1 et le patron de m6 pour ne pas
faire big brother qui était le programme
c'est ça d'origine et il ya cette phrase
de nicolas tavernost les pathologistes
mais je ne ferai pas big brother mais je
rien ne dit que je ne peux pas faire big
sisters et sur le story après moi ce que
je pensais que c'était trop novateur
pour tf1 était à l'époque vraiment la
chaîne de référence
il prenait un trop gros risque à lancer
ce type de plomb c'était bien sûr au
final c'était bien mais sur une chaîne
qui devait le challenge est là mais
rappelé benjamin castaldi
comment ça s'est passé qui vous happe
les benjamins pour être l'animateur de
la valeur à l'époque c'est alexis jiminy
gaieté sur m6 c'est ça mais est ce que
je peux vous dire c'est que directeur
des divertissements de la vérité c'est
que j'ai été le 50e qu'ils appelaient
parce que personne ne voulait pas dans
quelle province et les voitures
l'égalité c'est ça c'est que ils m'ont
appelé moi est ce que tout le monde vers
fait dans paris pensez à oui moi j'étais
très content parce que déjà j'étais dans
une nouvelle vie il fallait que je
travaille donc j'étais né
nouvelle star est osée que moi la scène
constantin et merci les dépenses et/ou
losail pour acheter ses livres que l'ua
n'était pas dévoiler d'aller jouer mais
c'était parce que dans ces cas à
l'époque moi j'aimais niveau de trucs là
je vais les faire mais surtout je veux
un contrat pour la rentrée parce que
c'est ça qui m'intéresse
et c'est vrai que le loft où ils m'ont
vendu comme un programme intelligent
sociétal pas du tout pas du tout ce
qu'on a découvert pendant des années
quand tu quand tu leur voix à des années
après c'est en fait c'est ce kit avait
vendu pour moi c'est un programme
enrichi ses troupes moi je vois je vois
pas quelle est la polémique quand on
voit les images du havre et pourquoi ça
fait une telle polémique
voilà dans ce programme les candidats
vont donc être enfermé tous ensemble
durant soixante dix jours totalement
isolée du reste du monde et filmé h 24
regardez première vidéo de love story
d'enfermement une fois cette porte
franchie pour les candidats c'est le
point de non retour
dès cet instant ils vont découvrir
l'univers qu'ils occupent temps pendant
70 jours
ici ils sont complètement coupés du
monde ce qui veut dire la télévision pas
de radio pas de téléphone pas de
journaux absolument aucun contact avec
l'extérieur
ce jardin de 380 mètres carrés orientée
plein sud va devenir leur jardin dans
les 225 m² du loft les habitants une
cuisine toute équipée avec four et
plaques électriques mais pas de lave
vaisselle lave vaisselle c'est à la main
et c'est chacun son tour
autre règle collective faire le ménage
il est à la charge de tous les candidats
de tous sans exception à quelques mètres
du salon le confessionnal une fois à
l'intérieur le candidat s'installe dans
ce fauteuil
il peut alors communiqué avec un membre
de la production par caméras interposées
alors donc avec shell y avait une scène
qui retransmettait 24 heures sur 24
d'ailleurs 23 heures sur 24 ces 24 24 la
première rivale cadenas et après s'est
passé avec la fameuse heure c'est ça à
23 heures alors c'est vrai que c'était
donc en quotidienne plus y avait le sait
reste un énorme pari pour m6 et la
carton d'audience où vous avez tué
jusqu'à combien d'audience sur les
cantons n'était plus entre 6 et 7
millions à 19 heures c'est ça devant tf1
très loin de leur existence et
j'aimerais monter à 12 une union sont
nés au final il aimait mais on a été la
première fois qu'en fait tf1 était battu
mais il faut savoir que big brother dans
tous les pays où ça a été lancée c'est
une petite chaîne qui récupère du mans
bat et qui devenu avec le brame numéro
un dans son pays celtiques et en
hollande c'était le cas dans tous les
pays vous avez lancé vous pour le coup
c'était un pari absolument incroyable
alors tf1 avait débranché le canal b 6
ouais ça alors on était dix cellules un
os que les gens à arrêter de bosser à
tf1 pour regarder voir des humains
c'était un phénomène à moi même mon père
vous dit qu'il est médecin
d'ailleurs tout le monde regarde et je
vais regarder love story c'était
incroyable orchila et voilà il n'y a pas
du tout sa part gardé de foyers câblés
13 millions de pages écrites sur le loft
à l'époque je passe si vous me direz ce
que ça représente mais moi j'avais une
question moi j'avais entendu dire qu m6
avait décidé de faire
love story en ayant appris que tf1
s'apprêtait à les trahir en faisant
colons table malgré le pacte qui avait
été signé voilà et alors que ces
théories sont parfaitement raison et
donc je dis toujours c'est marrant parce
que je produis koh lanta et je dois ma
carrière à koh lanta au final l'histoire
veut qu'ils lancent que l'entente dans
c'est pas de la télé réalité
donc on n'est pas d'accord on a on a
respecté le deal nicolas tavernost dit
non vous n'avez pas respecté le deal est
toute l'histoire a été conçue avant
koh-lanta et koh lanta n était pas une
démission en direct l'émission
enregistré avec beaucoup de montage ils
ont fait beaucoup de problématiques de
montage au lancement de la première
saison et six mois exactement et on les
a coiffé au poteau gauche